on the dish this morning the company
that's been feeding America since the
beginning founded in 1790 King Arthur
was launched at the same time George
Washington was giving his first State of
the Union Address ever since it's been
King when it comes to flower the
building block of our baked goods even
after 230 years however times keep
changing as we found out on a recent
visit
[Music]
way up Vermont near the border with New
Hampshire is a picturesque town called
Norwich
featuring the mecca of baking
at King Arthur they make mouth-watering
pastries and bread
cell baking products offer a cafe King
Arthur Baker's hotline this is David and
even a call center where anyone with a
baking emergency can reach out yeah
absolutely if it's in the refrigerator
the yeast activity is slowed down quite
a bit not to mention a classroom where
Amber Eisler their school's baking
director showed us the finer gentler
points of the croissant baking process
so we are going to whack this butter so
we're going to do that by or not see how
yours is flying off in mine didn't right
yeah give it a little twist of the wrist
[Music]
all right you're doing great okay
that's probably enough okay
it was violent
well I was just she said to whack it
Bam Bam and Amber will get back to the
croissant making in a second but first a
little more about this place
King Arthur is one hundred percent
employee owned and built on the
foundation of a famous red bag a beacon
to baking connoisseurs that recently got
a different name and logo some people
come in here and start crying we believe
strongly in the power of baking Karen
kohlberg is the co-ceo of the King
Arthur Baking Company King Arthur was
The Flower company for 230 years yes and
then became King Arthur Baking Company
why
we want to be the teacher of baking we
want to be the inspiration for baking
remaining relevant being current wanting
to be around for another 200 years we
needed to change the Rebrand and change
the name of the company because we'd
always been a Baking Company
so now to form the croissant we're going
to pick up a piece of dough and just
gently elongate a little bit this will
give us more layers as we roll it up and
then where there was that Notch at the
top we're just going to open it up a
little bit
and then we'll fold it over
and begin rolling so you can walk it all
the way or you can just
roll oh yes look at that perfect
all right there you go thank you
wow we let our croissants rise for a
couple hours enco them in an egg wash
before putting them in the oven to bake
for about 20 minutes
the main ingredient is King Arthur's
unbleached white flour
in 2020 alone the company sold
156 million pounds of it
Martin Phillip is King Arthur's baking
Ambassador the mindset that we use to
approach baking is different than I
would than what I do for cooking cooking
is in many ways a pro improvisational
right baking is not that baking is about
setting a course and using Precision to
a degree to control what goes into the
bowl to have the best outcome the people
who often do the best baking are like
Engineers or you know people like that
who bring that mindset because you're
looking at something far off yeah you
know baking takes time you know it's
like making wine bread makers are like
the wine makers of the sort of
carbohydrate World Philip believes
unconditionally in the power of baking
to not just bring ingredients but people
together
which is why after the 2016 election he
set out on a road trip back to where he
grew up there was more division in
society than what is necessary or even
normal and so I looked at food as a way
to come together and so I took the
ingredients to make biscuits put a banjo
on my back and got an old bicycle and
went back to where I'm from in Arkansas
and just started riding in cold calling
homes and trying to talk to people
because you think biscuits and banjos
can bring people together I I think so
what I figured was that
if they didn't like the music they could
at least eat a biscuit you know what I
mean so it was a hedge a little bit for
yeasted breads we want to control the
temperature of the dough right today
Philip develops recipes for King Arthur
and stars in their instructional videos
which reach Millions
is your goal to try to get people to eat
new kinds of bread or to get better at
baking the bread they already make yes
yeah definitely both I mean
what we want to do is write recipes
which are based on the foundations of
baking which make beautiful bread but
also bring ingredients in that are
compelling so this one has Italian black
rice and black sesame in it there you go
thank you you're welcome I'll trade you
into that
it's nutty as hell right it's nutty as
hell I kind of like the thin cut yeah
you do yeah I think there's a lot to be
said for the fact that Community you
know
is where you know baking began and
Community grew out of that I think food
is where Community began right and I I
believe that and I see it every day
because we produce content that touches
people across the world and we hear from
them so the next time you're working on
your baguettes is your croissants you
have a question you can give us a call
uh yes those croissants all right let's
cut into one and see how we did
look at that do you see that kind of the
honeycomb shape yeah beautiful all right
Cheers Cheers
wow
they were so good we established fairly
quickly that I don't always have the
patience required to bake properly you
did not do well on the butter whacking I
didn't whack the butter well
um was that butter I thought that was
it's high fat European butter wow she
told me to crush it so I crushed it and
I but it was it all over the place you
know what Jeff you did crush the pizza
this bread is amazing yeah so we have
five seeds sourdough in front of you can
I try this one yeah just take the
therapy sure the five seed Sesame has we
have some butter here there's some jam
with it and some honey by the way it
doesn't need anything on it
so good
yeah you didn't bake that though right I
did not make this they sent it to